oh nice hugs thank you wow it's a rental
right yeah yeah
[Music]
wait wait wait wait where are we going
Felix
[Music]
you'll go home
honestly
home doesn't mean the same for me as it
was for you in Phoenix
well why don't you come home with me
I'm just open
sure
can I see why Felix likes you so much
you're so um
real
Oliver
I have a complete and utter horror of
ugliness ever since I was very young I
don't know why I mean because you're a
terrible person
half the people get lost in salt Moon
this place it's not for you
I can honestly say that these last few
months have been the happiest of my life
anything else I should know about well
not just be yourself they'll love you
it's relaxed I promise
[Music]